okay welcome to another episode of q a
about history of science and technology
so i'm happy to talk about
both things that i've been personally
involved in and things i might have
studied from the more ancient past
i will say i just posted something uh
about a little
uh
thing that um we're doing to kind of
contribute to the development of science
at least
which is launching our wolfram institute
and
the
we are in an interesting situation
the science that we've been doing that's
come from
well a big tower of ideas
and tools
but most recently as kind of blossomed
in our physics project
has led to
just
a remarkable kind of new direction in
science that uh
revolves around this idea of
multi-computation
i i kind of identify multi-computation
as sort of a fourth big paradigm for
thinking about modeling and science
just to say something about that
it's uh kind of a little bit revolves
around a changing view of the notion of
time
through
different
levels of different epochs in the
modeling process in science
and
kind of
back in antiquity sort of the main issue
in modeling things in the world was kind
of what are things made of
you know are things made of atoms or
things made of corpuscles or things made
of whatever what are things made of
and and that's kind of a a type of uh
approach to thinking about things in
science doesn't really have much
reference to time it's more a structural
kind of approach
and many fields of science are still
very much dominated by kind of a
structural approach to thinking about
things
then you know move forward in history
1600s sort of big
thing at that time was this idea of
mathematical equations
as
a way to describe things in nature we
just say
the law of gravity is such that there's
this force
associated with objects that are this
distance apart and so on mathematical
equations as a way to describe the world
in mathematical equations kind of time
enters
as
a parameter just a variable that you can
sort of tune to any value you can turn
to any value you want
so then kind of the next big step i
would say
was in the in the 80s 1980s
uh something that i was deeply involved
in myself
which is this idea that one can use
programs
and computation as a way to model things
that happen in the world and sort of a
key idea there was
you have a rule for specifying how
things work that rule is kind of a
computational rule and to know what's
going to happen in the system you just
keep applying that rule and that
generates kind of this this
strand of behavior through time
and the progress of time is something
that corresponds to the the progress of
that computation and one of the big
things that i figured out is this
concept of computational irreducibility
the idea that to work out what will
happen in that computational process
there may be no faster way to do it than
to essentially follow each step and and
see what happens
so the new thing
is this thing we call multi-computation
and kind of the idea there is that one's
dealing not just with an individual
computation but the interactions between
a whole entangled collection of
computations
that's something that we kind of tipped
off to by thinking about quantum
mechanics but it turns out to be a
vastly more general phenomenon and
something which has the feature that
once you know that things are
multi-computational once you know that
there are these many possible threads of
computations which branch which merge
and so on there is a certain inevitable
structure when there's underlying
computational irreducibility there's a
certain inexorable structure to the
things that are produced by this
multi-computational process
the other feature is that instead of
there being a single thread of time
there are many threads of time and the
only way you can kind of tell what
happened in the system is to have some
observer who samples the system uh
slicing across the states of many of
those threads of time
so what we discovered first is that this
is super relevant to physics and it's
kind of a core part of how physics seems
to work
that was uh sort of emerged a couple of
years ago
then
what we've realized is that there are
lots of other areas
where
this kind of idea uh lets you make
progress in a sense in the 1980s we kind
of realized that there were fundamental
limitations on science associated with
computational irreducibility
and that made it seem like oh there are
things where it's going to the behavior
is going to be very complex and you're
not going to be able to make sort of
global predictions about it but what has
emerged now is that in multi-computation
with particular kinds of observers
and sometimes there are observers who
are like us in various ways with
particular kinds of observers it is
possible to make kind of global
statements that's where the laws of
physics as we know them things like
general relativity and quantum mechanics
that's where those come from is the
ability to make global statements from
this kind of multi-computational system
so in any case that idea kind of now
starts to give on the opportunity to it
really lets one open up sort of
scientific progress and the creation of
global laws for lots of other areas of
science so the one that i just spent
many months on is meta mathematics and
the physicalization of matter
mathematics i think we made some very
interesting progress there that kind of
unsticks something which has been kind
of stuck for 100 years or so about
thinking about the foundations of
mathematics
but this multi-computational idea
applies to lots of other areas i mean
one that we're just starting to look at
is what i call sub chemistry i'm looking
at kind of the detailed molecular
interactions that leads to chemical
processes going on rather than just the
amount of chemicals the sort of detailed
choreography of molecules and that's
relevant for thinking about
molecular computing it's also i suspect
very relevant for understanding
fundamental
mechanisms in molecular biology and
immunology in areas like that
and i think this multi-computational
approach
has applications in economics it
certainly has applications in
distributed computing that we're working
out uh just now
it has applications i think potentially
in linguistics in evolutionary biology
in neuroscience
um
all sorts of different areas it's really
quite exciting and it feels like it's
sort of a moment when we're really going
to be able to make dramatic progress in
a lot of areas because we have a really
new methodology that we get to apply to
those areas and so now the question is
structurally how do we do this
and you know i have a small group that
um you know i thought the bill for um
that
is um
working on our basic science we have a
larger group of people that are
affiliated with with our our group
working mostly on physics related um
initiatives to do with our physics
project
and the
the challenge now is well all these
different areas what are we going to do
with them how do we how do we kind of
make progress in all these areas and
that progress requires
talented people working in these areas
but actually it requires another thing
as well it requires strategy
for how to do the r d in these areas to
really make rapid progress and one of
the things that i'm pretty pleased with
is that over the last 35 years
in our company from research we've
really developed a i would say i think
it's rather impressive
machine
for basically
innovating and delivering research and
development results
and
that kind of mechanism is something that
as i say we put lots of effort into
making it as efficient as possible we
built tools both at the level of
technology software and so on and tools
at the level of management and kind of a
cultural structure that allows us to
make that kind of rapid progress
with a very talented team where and we
know kind of that team sort of we have
the the mechanisms to identify more
people for the team we have our summer
schools and we have a large network and
so on and we also have uh uh kind of
we've sort of we've cracked the problem
30 years ago of having a geo-distributed
operation
and uh
having that energetically make progress
so we've got kind of the machinery to
make progress
and we've applied that machinery in the
last couple of years to the physics
project now to the mathematics project
and so on the results are i think quite
spectacular
so now the question is how do we scale
that up and apply it to all these
different fields
and
the answer is we've got we've got the
methodology we've got the ideas and
we've got the sort of organizational
capability to do it
how are we actually going to do it
in a company
like ours ultimately
some companies do it in a funkier way
but with our kind of rather
uh direct business model um we are just
making things that people
uh
have value to people and the people to
whom they have value by them and so it's
it's kind of an ecosystem where we are
putting in lots of research and
development lots of innovation to make
products that
we then support all that all that r d
from
from the revenues from those products
now truth is we probably go a little bit
out of hand because we're probably
developing things which might be 50
years ahead of the market
and the fact that we're motivated to do
that is sort of an internal motivation
it's not something that's directly
driven by the market but the fact that
we can do that is a consequence of our
success in the market and our ability to
generate revenue from the the things
that we do in the market
and
uh as i say i've i've just
used some of that to do what we've been
doing in basic science last few years
but generally basic science is you have
kind of a choice you can say no i'm
going to keep it as something where i'm
going to generate value by some kind of
direct commercial loop
of course as the time scales for that
direct commercial loop get long enough
50 years 100 years those are not things
that are realistic to uh to be part of
some sort of uh
you know commercial investment kind of
kind of strategy that one might have
so so what's what's plan b
well plan b is do it for the world
do it as a piece of basic science do it
in the kind of open science approach
that we've been taking of of posting all
our intermediate uh uh results and and
live streaming things and all those
kinds of things do it for the world
but of course if you do it for the world
somehow the world has to support that
activity and so one needs some an
ecosystem that isn't just based on well
we have this thing that comes from
revenue that we make from creating tools
for a whole variety of things and then
we'll sort of cipher off a piece of that
to use for basic science we'll needs a
more systematic approach to supporting
that basic science
and it's always challenging to
understand
why should basic science happen it's
kind of a paradox it's something where
everybody i think would agree a lot of
people would agree that in the long view
of sort of the development of
civilization and history and so on that
the development of basic science is
important a lot of the things we have
today were made possible because of
basic science that was done
differing amounts of time in the past
whether it was the discovery of dna
whether it was the invention of calculus
uh you know these things happened in
their time
and it took times from decades to
centuries before that basic science
turned into things where you could say
look it it helps people's lives on an
everyday basis
it's something of commercial importance
it's something of
importance for countries or whatever
else
um so it takes a variable amount of time
and there's this kind of model of saying
it's sort of a public good
we're doing basic science we're just
going to put it out there for the world
for the public
and then the question is how does that
why should anybody support that because
it's sort of benefiting everybody so why
should anybody actually do anything
about it
and
for me
i'm i can do a certain amount about it
because i have certain resources and i'm
i find the basic science really
interesting and that motivates me to to
develop it
but that only goes so far
and in the end as you scale it up it has
to be something which has a sort of
broader base of support
now in general
the thing that always makes basic
science sort of easy to support
is when
the the entity that's supporting it
somehow has a monopoly on the channel by
which the basic science will get used
and even if it's going to take 50 years
for that basic science to be important
if the entity that's supporting it kind
of believes it sort of got a monopoly on
on those kinds of time scales even
perhaps a shorter time scale even even a
decade or less um but it's kind of it's
basic science you're putting it out
there in the world but only
only some particular entity has sort of
the distribution channel to take
advantage of that so in a classic
situation in sort of monopoly industries
like bell labs in its time
um like ibm in its time um
and uh
where you know if there's a if there's
an advance in basic science that has is
going to benefit telecommunications well
the company that's sort of running
telecommunications for the largest
economy so to speak is the one that's
going to get the lion's share of the
advantage and so it makes perfect sense
for that entity to support basic science
same is true with the us government in a
situation where the us economy is the is
substantially the largest in the world
it's something which leads to great
greater economic progress is something
that it makes sense to support as a as a
as a government kind of thing as a
matter of basic science now people
support basic science for other reasons
governments support it as a way to
keep a base of of people within their
country who know about sort of advanced
kinds of things and often has a certain
national pride associated with it and so
on
uh occasionally for companies it's like
it's cool to sort of wave the flag and
say our company was involved in
discovering some significant piece of
basic science it's an interesting
question whether our physics project um
you know exactly how that relates to
uh what um
what what
our main business of selling
computational language tools and so on
um i know that for me
the the project was made possible by the
you know 40 years of development of
those tools without those tools the
project would not have been possible i
also know that from that project i have
learnt a lot that is going to allow us
to produce a new generation of those
tools that will have lots of
applications
but as a direct matter i don't know how
it relates so in any case it's uh
what we what we intend to do
with the wolfram institute
is
uh where
so how does one support this how does it
work
um how do people uh
provide support for it how do
organizations provide support for it uh
the the fundamental thing that they're
supporting is people because the
fundamental thing we want to do is
advance basic science
and we're uh
the the when it comes to you know doing
big experiments and telescopes and
particle accelerators and all those
kinds of things
um
that's that's not kind of the the part
of this that we're planning to
concentrate on and there seem to be
quite a lot of people who are who are
very happy to pursue that if only we can
do some intermediate basic science to
get to the point of saying there's this
specific prediction about this
particular thing and so on it's a little
bit less direct in the case of something
like subchemistry
that's a place where thanks to uh our
friends at emeralds who've developed
this automated biology and chemistry lab
um it looks like it's actually possible
for for the likes of me to directly do
uh kind of biology and chemistry
experiments which allow us to sort of
explore that area um in physical form
well in any case i i could i could uh
talk about some kind of the the life and
times of basic research institutes i've
known many um and uh kind of what it
takes to
to make those things uh vibrant i think
one very big difference between what
we're planning and what has
traditionally been done
is that you know we have a definite
management model and the management
model uh in the end it's it's kind of my
initiative so to speak as my leadership
trying to actually move these projects
forward that's what i've been doing for
the last 35 years for our company and
more than that um for other kinds of
projects that i've done
um and i think that uh what we're kind
of relying on is this concept of sort of
managed basic research
what you see in most cases when people
say we're going to start a basic
research institute is it's a much more
feral kind of situation
where it's like let's get some some good
researchers and sort of put them
together
and they'll all do interesting things
and they'll all go off in different
directions and so on that's kind of not
the model that we intend to adopt the
model we intend to adopt is scaling up
in a basic science direction of the
kinds of things that we've learned to do
with our company where it's like we've
got a definite strategic direction we
want to figure out how to do
sub-chemistry and how to apply it to
microcomputing
that's the definite direction and now
it's a question of of going in that
direction and delivering basic science
in that direction
now it's an important sort of footnote
to that that we're making the decision
we're going to go in that direction and
we're not going to do it for the sake of
saying we're going to have some you know
commercial delivery at the end of it
that is going to be directly a product
we're going to actually do it as basic
science for the world so to speak um and
that's the model at this point in my
life and i think in the in the evolution
of these ideas that's the stage that is
the most productive to be at rather than
saying let's let's find this particular
thread from which we can derive
something of of direct commercial
applicability and and pursue that and
that alone so to speak i think it's much
much better for the world and personally
i think it's more interesting right now
to pursue this broader sort of pure
basic science kind of approach
so that's kind of what we're what we're
planning to do now there are some
interesting sort of side comments to
make about um uh one of my little
personal challenges is to see to what
extent one can use kind of uh
the the tokenization of everything and
to what extent one can think through
is there a way to kind of develop basic
research the value of basic research
in a way that can be described defined
by
uh some some form of of token um it's
sort of the exercises if one knew that
calculus
was going to generate trillions of
dollars of value and i knew that in 1687
what is a way to kind of make use of all
that
future value
and you know it might not be certain but
there will be an expectation of of
future value what is a way to make use
of that
back in the late 1600s so to speak to be
able to develop the field more quickly
rather than waiting for 100 years for
something to happen you know is there a
way to make use of the sort of dynamics
of of markets and so on to accelerate
that kind of thing and i'm i'm a little
bit of the way towards figuring that out
and maybe i'll talk about that another
time or talk about that people are
interested in that
um
so aaron asks
what skills would an incoming fellow for
our waltham institute have and what
would be effective preparation i think
what we're going to be so first of all
knowing the software
tools things like wolfram language and
so on that's a that's a critical thing
because that's kind of that's the
tooling that's going to allow us to to
sort of be
uh
be able to do things at a rapid rate in
in what we're what we're creating with
waltham institute i mean again that's
sort of a
i wouldn't call it an unfair advantage
that we have uh it's you know we built
this giant tower of tooling and by the
way anybody in the world can get access
to it so it's not like it's it's secret
knowledge but it is something where
since we've been involved in building it
um it's uh and architecting it um there
seems to be a certain concentration of
knowledge about that in people around um
around us
i think the summer school is is sort of
the a very good on-ramp
for the institute and institute fellows
and i think we'll probably our first
round of fellows uh will
will uh many of them may come from that
source
um for a bunch of the projects that we
are now embarking on we definitely need
people who have particular expertise
particular expertise in molecular
biology particular expertise in
economics particular expertise in
neuroscience evolutionary biology etc i
think the the kind of the intersection
of that particular expertise with
knowledge of tools
that's a really good start i think
that's probably more important
than well for those areas that's more
important for those areas that are that
are fairly uh just getting started um
that's more important than specific
knowledge of for example our physics
budget now one part of what we'll be
doing is more work on the physics
project and i would say that more work
on sort of the formal structure of the
physics project and the mathematical
physics around it more work on kind of
connecting the physics project to
experimentally measurable things
in that second case
it's it's absolutely knowing about
actual physics and practical kinds of
things um understanding things which can
be related to actual physical
experiments and so on
now we also intend to have
kind of a
an on-ramping mechanism we have the
summer school we have our high school
summer camp we have now a middle school
camp these provide a kind of pipeline
for people learning both the the tools
the ideas and the methodology that we've
developed
and it's certainly my hope that we can
scale up that kind of
that kind of outreach and that kind of
channel and pipeline for people who have
the right kind of expertise to i think
contribute energetically to the
directions that we're going and you know
it's it's really an interesting thing
because there's this sort of there's
this tremendous setup of science
opportunities that exist
and we have a methodology and tooling
for exploring them and we have a flow of
people interested in being involved so
now we just have to put that together
and in a sense you know i've i've spent
a large part of my life uh
you know i i have run a lot of things in
my life so in addition to i i like doing
things myself
but i also like running things and using
the things that i run as sort of
machines to amplify the kinds of things
that it's possible to to do
you know back in 1986
i started a research institute center
for studying the sort of emerging field
of complexity that i kind of
worked to develop in the in the early to
mid 1980s
um
that was an operation uh at university
of illinois
and called center for complex systems
research
and i think it was in some ways
successful in some ways
not successful at least in my definition
of success
it was successful in the sense that we
brought in a lot of very capable people
um and uh had had a good group of people
it was unsuccessful in the sense that i
don't think i mean many different
specific things got done there and many
you know significant papers got written
and things like that
uh personally i
very rapidly exited the picture because
it became clear that sort of managing a
thing like that in the context of an
organization like the university was not
a great optimization of my skills
and uh so i started our company often
research at that time and uh kind of uh
have used that as my vehicle for for the
things that i've done ever since
um i think that um the other thing that
um
i didn't do was i didn't set the
expectation that i was going to in
detail
lead the kind of r d effort that we had
at our at our research center um instead
it was more like bring in good people
and have them do good things
rather than this is a project it's going
to be project managed it's going to have
milestones it's going to be a thing
where we've actually got objectives
where the objectives change but it's
going to be something where whatever
tenacity and intensity i might have in
leading things is going to be directly
applied to the project
and uh with wolfram institute i intend
that i and and people working with me
will apply sort of tenacity and
intensity to projects and it's not going
to be just a
more of a bringing good people and let
them do what they feel like kind of kind
of thing it's more bringing good people
and have them be part of this flow that
we're creating that um that leads to
something that none of us on our own
could do
that is something that is that is a
a a um a project that to which there
need to be many contributors but they
have to be pointed in the same direction
if they're kind of pointed in random
directions it is a different it is much
less effective than if they can be that
if there's actual one part of the
project is leadership to point things in
in a uniform direction
so
let's see
um
morgan is asking what is the emerald
functionality that's mentioned
uh for biological cellular computational
exploration actually it's a company
started a decade ago
um
currently uh it's
um based in south san francisco although
it's about to have a
a big piece that's uh kind of in the
carnegie mellon orbit in the pittsburgh
area
um
it's uh
uh
it's a company whose goal is to automate
biology and chemistry lab experiments
and they've so far automated about 200
of those experiments
and i was just looking at their hplc
experiments
and uh it's a little bit scary that okay
so the whole thing is programmed in
morphing language but you know
the
the the documentation for the hpsc thing
is really really long and it's got a lot
of details about you know the buffer
reagent and the this and that and the
others got lovely pictures of uh
idealized pictures of of those machines
those are idealized pictures but
in their actual facility there are
actual machines controlled by
some excuse me
as i was saying
um anyway in their actual facility
these are machines controlled by robots
and with some people and so on in the
loop
and kind of the idea the concept is you
write a wolfram language script which
describes an experimental procedure that
you want to actually be executed
in physical experimentation and then the
results come back to wolfram cloud
uh for you to analyze and explore
so i was
i'm hoping that we'll be able to explore
our kind of sub chemistry uh ideas um
directly by doing physical experiments
actually i just had a long piece of mail
about that from uh from folks there um
and uh
uh about
how to actually start on various pieces
of this i was going to do a a trial
project of taking the fake my favorite
brand of chocolate and trying to figure
out um uh how many wonderful compounds
it has in it that's just a
kind of a very very quick um
introduction to doing uh sort of a
remote physical lab experiments before
we start trying to actually compute the
primes of molecules
or anything more dramatic like that
um but in any case it's a i think it's
it's really uh
it's something for me
it's a very important
uh piece of tooling for being able to do
physical chemical and biological
experiments
um without
uh having uh spent years learning how to
pipette and you know how to do a western
blot and all those kinds of things um
and uh those are those are things which
it's now and this is typical of the
progress of of science and technology
it's something where we've now got a
layer of automation and so we just have
to know what to do not how to do it so
to speak
um
let's see woman is asking about overseas
and other countries but i don't know
what the context of that is
um
uh
okay so happy is commenting that
wonderful things come out of pursuing
science just for the sake of it
um
and that people often say it's just a
fishing trip it's just some kind of
stamp collection effort but that in fact
when people pursue things they for their
own sake they often produce some
um
great
great ideas i uh
happy mentions pcr technology
i certainly knew carrie mullis the
inventor of pcr a bit i'm not quite sure
of the full story of the of the
invention of pcr but i'm not sure it was
quite a um
uh
was quite a story that was i think a
more directed kind of story
but any case i think it's worth
commenting on on sort of
how you get great things out of basic
science
first thing is a lot of the story of
basic science is knowing what question
to ask
and that already frames sort of a
context for how to move things forward
that's that's one thing another thing is
sometimes there'll be a piece of basic
science and you don't have any idea
when
you know at some point in the future
you're going to pick it off the shelf
and say wow we can do something terrific
with that
i mean an example for me personally the
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that i
started working on in the 1980s
that
i think became sort of a a stimulus for
the idea of proof of work for
cryptocurrencies something i never would
have guessed
the concept that sort of the need to do
irreducible computational work would
turn into let's use that as a kind of
analog of the difficulty of mining gold
or something and and have that be the
basis for the sort of store of value in
cryptocurrencies very bizarre connection
which i wouldn't have made i'm sure when
alan turing in 1936 was working on his
paper on computable numbers with an
application to this decision problem
that he didn't imagine
that a few years later those concepts
will be used to make things like word
processors and to do the things that
were the sort of
uh that are the practical uses of
computers and so on it's often hard to
imagine those things
and i think what basic science
contributes is
it often provides a new context for
thinking about things it provides the
tooling and the raw material you need so
that when the world has gotten to a
point where you suddenly need that kind
of technology you can sort of wheel it
in and make use of it
i think it's an interesting thing for
example in mathematics
when
there is if you look at sort of the
developments of pure mathematics over
the course of years which ones have been
later taken off the shelf to actually be
used for something
so for example
in uh i don't know differential
equations okay they were taken off they
were they were as they were created they
were kind of taken off the shelf and
used for things difference equations
less so they were created before long
before they were used i think
um
something like transfinite numbers uh
developed in the 1880s
it was still not quite at the point
where
we have a a pulling it off the shelf and
using it kind of
a kind of moment although perhaps for
that one as we think about infinite data
structures and things about
multi-computation and the uh and
different notions of of getting a result
from a computation maybe we finally 140
years later get to take transfinite
numbers off the shelf and start using
them for something which has
technological significance
but uh i think that that um uh the thing
to say about about the pursuit of basic
science
is the surviving pursuit of basic
science there's a certain aesthetic in
doing basic science where you're kind of
drilling down to the essence of things
and in my experience when you do that
well
the things you do will end up having
applications later but when you were
talking about just some very specific
corner of this and that the other which
doesn't have that kind of aesthetic
essence to it well often that'll be a
paper that's rarely read because it's
some detail of a detail and it's not
something that has that kind of a kind
of core foundational essence to it that
inevitably leads to applications i mean
i've been struck the the simple cellular
automata that i studied in the 1980s
that those are sort of the minimal
models the minimal rules of a certain
type and it's been remarkable how many
of those things have been applied as
models of particular kinds of things
because they are kind of the minimal
examples and so if you're going to start
from the minimum example you're going to
hit those things and those things as you
know about them will have properties
that can be applied in lots of places
so i think
sort of basic science
that really
sort of lives up to the aesthetic of
good basic science of really drilling
down to the essence of things that basic
science is sort of necessarily going to
be important um eventually it's
necessarily going to be the foundation
of something we may not yet have the
thing the sort of the the superstructure
we may not yet understand what it is
we're going to build on that foundation
because our ambient interests and our
ambient other technology haven't reached
the point where we can see why that's
important but it's sort of inevitable
that that foundation will eventually be
important and certainly in my own
efforts
in studying the computational universe
my big new kind of science book that's
just about to be 20 years old now
um and
these things we're doing now with kind
of multi-computational physics project i
feel extremely confident and certainly
the evidence i can see from the last 30
something years
is that uh those things which one has
really drilled down to the essence
one is going to are going to end up
being important as foundations for lots
of things that get done but
you know i don't think that's a sort of
a launch to just say do basic science
for the sake of doing basic science do
good basic science and it will be
important
and i think basic science has this
feature that is the upstream thing it is
the thing from which many many things
are derived
from my own life and work one of the
reasons that i'm so interested in kind
of the tooling and the creation of our
computational language is i know that
that's kind of an upstream thing that
enables a huge number of other things a
huge set of computational x's for sort
of all values of x so to speak of
different fields
and it feels like a very high leverage
kind of place in which to put one's
one's efforts it's something that is
sort of a a tooling or something which
is providing for as foundations for lots
of kinds of downstream things and that's
the way i feel about good basic science
as well
so um i but i think also
that
uh and i've seen this many many times
with my own activities
you take a field
and
you maybe say well i've got a practical
reason why i need to solve some problem
in that particular field
and
you think i don't know that field isn't
terribly interesting there's nothing you
know it's kind of mundane it's kind of
like well i know i can do it etc etc etc
you get into doing it and you realize
actually there are foundational
questions here which maybe people in the
field have tended to avoid because they
figured you know those are too hard and
we don't really need them for the
particular
for the particular thing we're aiming
for we don't need to solve those
foundational questions but if you allow
yourself the freedom to actually think
about those foundational questions well
gosh sometimes you can make big progress
and when you do it builds this huge new
tower that can be used in some field or
another that you wouldn't ever have got
to if you just made that straight you
know that straight kind of path towards
the particular problem you were trying
to solve
so i think that's a that's a feature
again of good basic science and of the
ability to have a little bit of freedom
to explore because if you say it's if
it's like well we got to get results in
three days three weeks three months
three years whatever um you know if
we've got to say well you've got to get
to that you know take the take the most
direct path to the answer just go find
the answer well yes
then you will be sort of uh the the
the freedom to do basic science will not
be there because you just don't have
time you've got to be rushing towards
that answer now it turns out
that may be the worst way to try and get
towards the answer you may never get
there by trying to make that direct path
because actually to get there you really
have to redo the foundations you really
have to understand something which is
not directly on that path i certainly
know for our physics project
to have gotten to the point that we've
gotten to required me to understand and
work on a bunch of areas which
if you just said oh is that going to
contribute to fundamental physics the
immediate answer would have been not a
chance
to understand more about uh the sort of
general computational universe what
programs typically do to understand
things like the principle of
computational equivalence and
computational irreducibility what does
that have to do with the fundamental
theory of physics
to understand more to have the tooling
to do things with graph theory and so on
that we have in world language to have
sort of various kinds of experience
in how big projects tend to come
together to have sort of certain kinds
of almost philosophical knowledge of
kind of
the structure of physics and so on are
things where you might have said you
want to find a fundamental theory of
physics that's not the way to do it the
direct way to do it is oh you take you
know string theory and you add a little
extra step on to the end of it and and
that's how you're going to get it you
know there's a path and you just go
incrementally along that path that's not
the way that one's going to be able to
do good basic science and often it's
that sort of uh seemingly random
exploration but i would say that for
myself and certainly this is what we
intend to to pursue at our institute
um it's do it well
and do it foundationally and then it
will be something that's important
and don't just do it
on the minimal path so to speak
and i think a general principle that
i've noticed is sort of if you are
approaching some kind of problem and
there's something which is that's the
really hard not really difficult part
head for that
because if you solve it you've cracked
the whole nut open so to speak
and often that thing is something that
surprisingly little has been done on
because people have always said that's
the difficult part you've got to stay
away from that let's go try and you know
sneak around the side and do the easy
parts and it may turn out the difficult
part has been untouched for 100 years
and that there is new new ideas new
tools new methods which then allow you
to approach that difficult part
in a different way that wasn't possible
100 years ago when that difficult part
was last looked at so that to me has
been a very successful approach and i
get we i guess we get to to follow that
kind of approach in doing the things
that we're doing applying these
multi-computation ideas and the things
we've learned from the physics project
to these different areas of science
um
let's see
um
ah comment from robin about overseas and
other countries outreach
and interaction with education systems
you know
the our summer school and summer camp
and so on
have had the
uh
and our company actually has the great
good fortune
to
have people involved from all over the
world
uh from
sort of the obvious countries and the
not so obvious countries
um and to me that's a source of kind of
great strength
in the different points of view that it
brings in to the kinds of things that we
do
um and uh
it's um
it's something where
on at the level of individual people i
would say that there's sort of a a very
broad geographic mixing
at the level of what governments do and
official education programs and so on
that's a much more complicated issue and
it's much more you know there are
particular successes of particular
things we're doing in particularly
somewhat smaller countries um where it's
kind of it's a little easier to kind of
turn the ship um and there's sort of
interesting things there and we see the
results of those and i think there's in
the current time when we look at sort of
the emergence of computational x for all
x
um many of those areas
are both still
very undeveloped
and also
the the tools for developing them are
tools often ones we've built for example
that
are very widely accessible to people
it's not the case that if you're in
country country x
that oh we can't do that kind of science
because we don't have a particle
accelerator well that's not true of
computational x
you know so long as you have computers
and pretty much everywhere does at this
point
you can use the tools that we built to
do computational x for some value of x
and um so that provides an opportunity
for different places to be able to
become sort of leaders in those
particular areas and it's sort of a
challenge to provide education that will
support that
now you know one of the things that's a
funny feature of the progress of science
i've been thinking about this quite a
lot recently
is the formation of what amounts to
scientific guilds
you know there is a particular area of
science
and maybe it's not so easy to understand
it's it's got a real stack of
intellectual uh ideas that one has to
kind of uh
absorb to get to the point where one is
fluent in that area and what tends to
happen is somebody invents it they have
students the students have students
there are great grand students etc etc
etc and eventually there's this kind of
there's this kind of um
uh
sort of
this guild that gets produced of people
who have direct personal contact who are
apprenticed to learn about that
particular kind of thing
and it's interesting to see and i
realized
that well that tends to build up these
fields of science now that can be that's
something which at some level may get
unhealthy because it's like well
everybody knows everybody in that guild
and everybody knows what they should do
and so nobody ever does anything that's
highly innovative because it's all just
doing what the guild does so to speak
but it's an interesting dynamic that you
end up with these sort of clumps of
people who know things i mentioned this
in connection with countries because it
can tend to be the case that that you
know there's some country with a lot of
very capable people but they just are
not connected to that guild so to speak
and so they never really understand how
to do let's say computational acts for
some acts
and certainly some things i've tried to
do have tried to sort of break down that
that kind of geographical barrier
but i think that's something that is not
so easy to do
and uh it's something that's one of the
challenges here is that a lot of what
develops is based on sort of personal
contacts and some of those are very
geographically geographically based
um i think that uh
if i look at my own
trajectory in science and so on one of
the things i realized just very recently
i'm sort of shocked i didn't realize
this before it's kind of an example of
doing history is sometimes harder from
the inside than just from the outside
that is when i study the historical
biographies of people i can kind of see
you know after the fact and from the
outside how to sort of join the dots of
why did this happen and then this
happened in this person's career but
sometimes a little harder to see that
for oneself and it takes real sort of
thought to see how that works but i've
noticed a thing which is that most areas
have this kind of guild type character
that you know oh the people who worked
in mathematical logic or they're
improving or whatever else or some area
they're all kind of a
a set of people who kind of know each
other and learn from each other in an
apprentice kind of way
well one of the things that i've done
many times actually is you know i'll
just read what people have written and
go try and do it myself
and i hadn't really realized how unusual
that actually is because and when people
when i've kind of worked in particular
fields and people are like oh my gosh
you're an outsider how come you're doing
interesting things in our field and
sometimes they're very positive about
that sometimes they're very negative
about that
um but
i sort of only just realized that that's
more unusual than one thinks
that most of the time people within a
field have have got there by some kind
of apprenticing process rather than by
just reading what people have written
using the tools that exist and just
diving right in um and you know i don't
really know what the cause of that
dynamic is um but that's something which
i've noticed in terms of sort of the
progress of different areas and that has
some effect on the relationship between
geography and progress and so on
uh
let's see
peter is asking about some
capabilities of mathematica or from
institute warfare institute is is really
about basic science
and it's about things that
uh are contributing to sort of the
corpus of ideas in the world and the
corpus of of the basic things that are
figured out
uh no doubt some of those things as has
been the case for other basic science
that i've done
will be usable to develop technological
kinds of things and to develop tooling
and things in both language and so on no
doubt that will happen but the big sort
of calculation here is let's do things
that where the motivation is basic
science
you know in the end when we're building
wolfram language the motivation is the
product the tool which is wolfram
language
um and something that people are going
to use
so
something that is a product that that
one sells et cetera et cetera et cetera
that's the goal there but for the
institute the goal is pure basic
research that is being put out there
into the world for anybody to use
without the motivation that it has any
sort of short-term uh commercial or
other value that its value is really an
intellectual value and a value it's sort
of a a gift to the to the future of the
world so to speak rather than something
where you can say
here's this thing it's you know
protected by intellectual property law
and we're going to you know take
advantage of it for ourselves so to
speak
um
so there's a question
uh
the um
yeah by the way this whole question
about some
uh guilds and geography and so on it is
quite interesting and i i it's something
that it's a piece of data science
somebody should do it to look at these
different fields you know take the
papers on archive we now have a wolf
language great ways to import the pdfs
and all that kind of thing you can you
can
you know grind them up and um see what's
there and so on um and ask the question
you know to what extent can you see kind
of the trade routes the geographical
trade routes
so to speak of different ideas you know
to what extent is it the case that we
really are in a global world when it
comes to for example science and to what
extent is it still
fairly local or for example at least
local on the student genealogical tree
of science so to speak
my guess is it's fairly local um that
ideas sort of don't jump very often
from uh you know just purely through the
literature so to speak that it tends to
be more through personal contact i don't
know it's a study one could do
um
so let's see
there's a question here about um
from uh
agostino
about uh my opinion about experimental
mathematics and its relationship with
classical quotes mainstream mathematics
okay so
people have done quotes experimental
mathematics for a long time
in the sense of sort of figuring out
what's true
often when people say we're pure
mathematicians we're going to prove
everything
they have a certain methodology and it's
like your paper is only worth anything
if it's got theorems and proofs in it
but the truth is people from gauss to
riemann
to euler to certainly ramanujan
many of the things they discovered they
discovered by playing around with
specific examples ramanujan particularly
famously for that although i think
people didn't understand that as clearly
then or even now that ramanujan
came up with all these incredible
formulas about you know all these
formulas for e to the uh
pi square root of 100 and
what is it 137 no 173 i've forgotten one
of those things is very close to an
integer and that allows you to derive
series for pi and a lot of things that
are just unbelievably ornate formulas
that just look utterly bizarre to people
and
revenue jan was a very good calculator
and he kind of got an intuition for when
something would be absolutely true and
then what its consequences would be but
if you asked him to write down you know
an epsilon delta proof for what he was
doing
he i'm sure he wouldn't have been able
to do it
and you know when he wrote to g.h hardy
uh in cambridge in
1913 or so i think 19 around that time
um and said you know i've got all these
bizarre formulas look at all these
bizarre formulas
and hardy was like oh my gosh this
person must be a brilliant
mathematical you know how could he have
derived all these theorems well the
answer was he was doing experimental
mathematics
and when hardy responded you know i've
proved some of your your results
ramanujan was like hey that's cool you
know now i know they're true
and because you know he had an intuition
that they were true and he had
calculations that suggested they were
true they didn't have a sort of formal
you know write it down in traditional
mathematics proof
and in fact he had some things wrong i
mean he thought he had proved things
about the prime number theorem about the
density of primes um which turned out
wasn't in the end true although the
counter examples were incredibly large
involves incredibly large numbers and
things like that and it wasn't uh it
wasn't he didn't have access to those uh
whereas for the theory of partitions for
example he nailed it he got from sort of
what started as a piece of experimental
mathematics he figured out what exactly
is going on and that was later proved
and so on
now
uh so you know when it comes to figuring
out what's true
i've certainly done lots of experimental
mathematics it's a very important
methodology it's a methodology that is
kind of often uh hidden in corners by
people who are uh you know because
there's this model of mathematics that's
a hundred and
you know
some 120 150 years old that says you
know mathematics is about you describe a
theorem you have certain axioms you
prove the theorem now truth is people
don't go all the way back to the axioms
you know i remember asking andrew wiles
shortly after he proved fermat's last
theorem so do you know what axioms you
used
no idea doesn't care it doesn't matter
whether it's just piano arithmetic
whether it's sap theory doesn't matter
what the the purpose of a proof is to
explain why the thing is true so other
mathematicians will understand it uh
which is a different thing from the sort
of the
official version of we're going to prove
it from pure axioms
that official version is becoming a
little bit more visible through ideas
like proof assistance um my own recent
work on sort of the physicalization of
metamathematics kind of makes one
realize sort of the limitations of that
way of thinking about the structure of
mathematics but that's kind of a
different story i think that
the thing that is remarkable about
experimental mathematics is you can if
you do it well you can find things you
didn't know were true
often experimental mathematics is just
done to sort of you know check off some
boxes or add an extra decimal place or
something more or less to something
where you already knew the structure you
already knew the context of what might
be true good experimental mathematics is
about discovering things we had no idea
that something like that was out there
my friend mitchell feigenbaum discovered
the universality of period doubling in
iterated maps by doing a piece of sort
of good experimental mathematics he had
a guess that there might be some kind of
scaling principle because he knew a
little bit about renormalization group
and things like that but he did the
experiment he didn't do the experiment
for the sake of finding that scaling law
because he didn't know it was there he
just did the experiment and saw what
happened and noticed this phenomenon
when i started working on cellular
automata back in the early 80s i had no
idea what i would find i had a definite
prejudice that what i would find would
be
simple rules simple would lead to simple
behavior i think the the one thing that
perhaps uh uh i'm i'm pleased happened
there was that i was sort of a careful
enough experimentalist and an
unprejudiced enough experimentalist that
when i discovered that the thing that i
thought was true wasn't actually true i
didn't say oh that can't possibly be
right but i did at first say that but
after a short while i i said look i can
check the experiment is what i thought
it was and by golly there's a phenomenon
i didn't expect
that's what it takes to do sort of good
experimental mathematics
it's also something where you know now
with our computational language and both
language and mathematica and so on you
can really describe what you're doing
and you describe it with a level of of
precision that is exceeds the level of
precision that you might use if you were
just presenting a proof
uh according to sort of fuzzily
according to maybe kind of axioms um the
you know if you have a piece of code a
piece of woven language code that that
says this is what we did and this is
what we got it's a very clear way to
communicate and the whole idea about
computational language is that it's
readable by humans as well as by
machines
so that's kind of a um uh and so so then
this idea of
uh
experimental mathematics it's like
physical experiments do you do the
experiment well and can you discover
things you didn't already know were
there unfortunately quite a lot of
experimental mathematics does not have
the property that it allows one to
discover or succeeds in discovering
things one didn't already know were
there it's more of a box checking
exercise but good experimental
mathematics is all about kind of getting
out of our kind of local domain of what
we already know is true because one of
the things that happens is
when you build mathematics sort of step
by theorem by theorem you're you're
doing it in a certain way as we now
understand from this physicalization of
matter mathematics
we're making what we call an entailment
tone where you're saying this theorem
entails this other theorem entails this
other theorem it's a it's a whole formal
structure
of kind of analogous to the light cone
in physics of what
what thing what mathematical result
entails what other mathematical results
but when you do experimental mathematics
you jump it's like you go in a meta
mathematical spacecraft and you're just
jumping to some completely other area of
metamathical space you're you're not
reliant on this kind of structure of go
sort of theorem by theorem step by step
axiom of application by axiom
application you're jumping somewhere
else now the problem with jumping
somewhere else is you may land there and
you may look around and you may say i
don't know what the heck is here
it's something totally alien it's
something i completely don't understand
and it's also something where i may have
no context for knowing why it's
important you know one of the things
that's very very ordinary sort of a
strange consequence of the story of
ramanujan is that ramanujan was somebody
who you know was a uh was a basically
a clerk in in the port of madras
in india
and although he had some uh uh
pretty decent education um but he was he
was employed as a human calculator to
add up you know
uh i don't know freight charges and
taxes and things like this
um which apparently he did very very
quickly but um
uh you know he was
sort of an amateur mathematician
kind of i mean he he was known in the in
the local area as a as a sort of a
notable mathematical person
um
but in any case uh you know he just in
the end wrote
these letters to g.h hardy who was a
well-known british mathematician
um uh which were just like his bunch of
formulas very weird kind of letter so
that tradition of just send a letter
with a bunch of formulas has i know
whether it pre-existed before revenue
but it certainly existed after revenue
jan and somebody like me
you know gets lots of these
and they're just sort of tables or
formulas or just mathematical results
that are like and so then the question
is do these mean something are they are
they correct do they mean something very
very hard to tell
i mean you know
it's it's
and
ranujan
was fortunate in a sense or was very
talented in being able to see the bigger
picture you know he got a zillion
formulas involving you know pies and and
elliptic functions and this and that the
other and he could sort of see how to
make kind of a coherent even though he
didn't really pull those threads
together he didn't explain those threads
but he could at least make a family of
formulas that seem to have relations to
each other and and that's something for
which to do that you have to have sort
of a bigger picture understanding what's
going on and just jumping in that
metamathical spacecraft and letting
yourself off at this weird place in meta
mathematical space where you can do a
piece of experimental mathematics and
discover something and say here's this
weird thing
is is not
is not so productive i mean i think one
of the big achievements in my effort my
new kind of science book
is that it contextualizes
what otherwise might just be sort of
point facts oh you take the cellular
automaton you run it and it produces
from simple rules you get very
complicated and seemingly random
behavior so what well the so what is
that you can build this whole new kind
of science around that phenomenon and
you know principles like the principle
of computational equivalence and so on
to kind of knit together those
individual discoveries that you make
so i think that's the um
that's the story there now now you know
it's worth pointing out that
it's become somewhat popular to have
these kind of uh proof assistance and
automated theorem proving and so on
automated theorem proving is not really
experimental mathematics or it has not
been used that way pretty much except by
me
um
and uh
automatic theorem proving tends to be a
story of we already know this is true
let's show that the computer can
actually fill in the steps of the proof
and usually what you get is something
incomprehensible to humans you know and
we're from alpha for example when we
have our step-by-step
uh results for students and so on we are
creating what amounts to a proof this
integral comes out this way but we're
creating a proof that has the setup that
it is
supposed to be understandable step by
step to
a human when an automated theorem
proving system says i can follow the
axioms and do this kind of jigsaw puzzle
in such a way that i can make a path
from from sort of the the
the origin to to the results i'm trying
to get that path will typically be
utterly incomprehensible to us humans we
won't have any kind of way of
understanding what's going on there
and
to my surprise actually i realized
recently that there's a result that i
found using automatic theorem proving in
the year 2000 i found the simplest axiom
system for boolean algebra for logic
just a single axiom involving six nand
operations and three variables
um
the uh and i found that using automatic
theorem proving
and um uh i believe that's the only
result that was unexpected has ever been
found with automated their improving in
all these years
actually that was a good example
of sort of the guild phenomenon because
because there had been sort of a guild
of people working on made they're
improving and they were i think it's
fair to say utterly shocked that
somebody would just come in and use what
they'd done
and discover something it was kind of
like you know that's only for the guild
kind of thing that's kind of unpleasant
in some ways but but um uh the um
the thing that was um
was interesting was kind of ironic
because because um back
in the early days of computer algebra
i had been a big user of systems that
people have built before mathematica
before my snp system
uh there were i've talked about this in
another one of these live streams the
history of computer algebra um there had
been back from the 1960s even there had
been a whole bunch of sort of
experimental and and uh and so on
systems that did computer algebra
and um but they had tended not to be
used outside of their guild they tended
to be used only with babies sitting from
their original creators and so on and i
suppose in retrospect i realized that it
was again a sort of surprising thing i
didn't think it was remarkable i didn't
think it was remarkable anytime in the
last 40 years i've only just now
realized it might be slightly more
remarkable that uh you know i sort of
came in from outside that field
and uh
just said look this is this is good
stuff these are great tools i can just
use these tools and um i you know
sometimes they don't work perfectly and
i have to kind of patch them up and so
on but i know enough to be able to do
that
um and you can just sort of dive in and
start using the tools and that's that's
a a thing that um uh for automated
theorem proving hadn't happened i mean
we're we're trying to make it automate
they're improving a little bit more
mainstream through its usable from
language and so on
and uh
we sort of implicitly use it quite a lot
maybe this work on metal mathematics
have done recently might help again to
sort of mainstream that a little bit
automatically improving sort of in a
sense isn't what you might think it is
in the sense it's not
giving you a human explanation of what's
going on
nor is it discovering things you didn't
know before it hasn't traditionally been
used that way
um it is instead more a validation
process for something that you kind of
already knew was true that's the
traditional way it's been used not the
only way it could be used and so for
example if we look at automated they're
improving today well the sort of the
branch of it that is proof assistance
okay and automatic theorem proving it's
like here are some axioms here's a
theorem go figure out if it's true and
generate proof
uh improve assistance it's more like
here you build up a set of human
understandable
mathematical statements and you kind of
you as a human try and fill in the
jigsaw puzzle and the proof of system
will tell you yes that piece fits in the
jigsaw puzzle in that way or no you've
got to try a different piece and sort of
a combination of those two things of
proof assistant
and
actual computational system like
language or mathematica or automated
theorem proving but i think more so or
from language that's something that's
potentially powerful although i have to
say i haven't really figured out exactly
how those should connect the workflow is
very different
one workflow and you know using wolfram
language you're trying to work out
things you didn't already know were true
or didn't already know what the result
is whereas in a proof of system you're
more trying to fill in the details of
something you're pretty sure is true
and i think the thing that's
particularly important
is enroll from language we put a lot of
effort into defining how to describe
things sort of making a description
language for concepts
and that's something which in the end is
critically important if you want to
actually make sort of large-scale
proof-of-system kinds of things work
i mean right now i think that sort of
validating protocols and things like
that is the most likely kind of
direction
for sort of uh near-term success of
things like proof assistance more so
than pure mathematics and i've
understood that now more through this
project on the physicalization of
metamathematics this notion that what
mathematicians do
is more sort of operating at the level
of sort of the fluid dynamics of
mathematics the the big large-scale
flows of what's connected to what rather
than the molecular dynamics of the
details of individual sort of axiomatic
steps and that that's more the picture
of mathematics that that emerges for
practical pure mathematicians not this
sort of low-level machine code kind of
approach
and that even with a low-level machine
code you can't necessarily uh decompile
it to the point where you have a larger
scale picture i mean that's exactly what
happens in automated theorem proving
like the proof of my um
uh axiom system for boolean algebra
is incomprehensible to humans actually
there was a person named norma gill
who was
just in the last oh
in the fall of last year finally took
him
upon himself to decode
that um
uh
uh that proof and try and simplify it to
the point where it was understandable to
humans and unfortunately he died last
december so that that initiative uh uh
stopped but um uh the um i i hope that
you know it's sort of an interesting
thing that 20 years have passed between
two years have passed and that proof is
still as incomprehensible as it ever was
and i think that's some
uh it's it's no good to say well i've
got this formal proof it's magnificent
nobody will ever understand it that's
not the mechanism of mathematical
progress that people have been used to
in in doing practical pure mathematics
so
um
let's see
the um
the question i mean
yeah you know just to just to finish on
this point about experimental
mathematics i mean i think there is a
good way to do experimental mathematics
and it is very much like the good ways
to do physical experiments you've got to
be careful you've got to be clear and
clean
describe what you're doing
well
you've got to have good pieces of
computational language code you've got
to have good visualization that lets one
sort of plug into our human ability to
perceive things you know if you've just
got a table of numbers you're very
unlikely to be able to notice the things
you want to notice just because our
human perception system is not as well
tuned in that case
we have you know lots of fibers going
from our
uh you know down our optic nerve that
communicate a lot of data from from
complete visual forms so to speak
um i would like to compare a little bit
the field of ruleology that we've
started talking about recently with
experimental mathematics
uh so ruleology is kind of a field
derived from this whole new kind of
science approach from exploring the
computational universe really ology is
about you write down computational rules
simple elegant
essential computational rules and then
you see what consequences they have
uh how does that relate to experimental
mathematics
well it could be a branch of that but
mathematics tends to involve certain
structures that have been traditional in
mathematics things like numbers
things like
geometry and so on whereas ruleology is
in a sense a lower level science it's a
science where the primitives are pure
arbitrary computational primitives
a rewriting of a string a structure that
is being transformed in this or that way
more so than having building on top of
sort of existing known mathematical
structures and experimental mathematics
is in a sense one can think of it as
perhaps it will emerge this way as a
branch of ruleology ruleology is the
more general field that is sort of given
a simple rule what will it do the
particular case of rules that have sort
of a mathematical resonance
becomes more experimental mathematics
but again
one feature of audiology is it's deeply
enmeshed with computational
irreducibility and much ruleology will
be necessarily you've kind of gone out
in a really old spacecraft and you're
off you know in a different place in
rural space exploring these rules and
what they do
and how that relates to kind of what we
normally think about and are interested
in is is something non-trivial to figure
out
and this whole sort of all these results
from multi-computation which show that
certain kinds of uh places in rural
space certain kinds of things
generically happen that's important in
making more coherence in that kind of
field but ruleology in and of itself is
already a very important field
just like for example chemistry is
already a very important field even
though you might not be able to join the
dots to know oh this kind of bromine
thing does that to that and so on it may
be
that you are just discovering this
particular chemical reaction is useful
or has this particular property and
that's useful because one day that that
is that piece of essential basic science
will be taken off the shelf and somebody
will say by golly we can use that to
fuel a new generation of rockets or
something
okay i should probably uh
wrap up soon um
uh
let's see oh my
you guys are asking lots of interesting
questions here
um
let me maybe uh
take
this one more here from parker
it says i often hear that science needs
philosophy to justify it what are some
historical examples of this
you know
the relationship between philosophy and
science is kind of interesting
if you're a practicing scientist
you kind of
you don't really think much about
philosophy let me give you an analogy
strange analogy
in wolfram language and mathematica
you do all kinds of computations
involving all kinds of numbers
but you rarely have to think about the
units for those numbers
because by the time you're industrially
doing a computation involving a million
numbers the fact that they're all in
meters or all in inches
that's already factored out you've
already you've done that you've taken
care of that and now you're in the in
the big industrial part where you're
studying things so it is with science
and philosophy in the sense that there
might be some philosophy that explains
why you should do this
but by the time you're dug in to
actually doing the details of the
science
that sort of seems irrelevant
now what's interesting
in so so for example in my life
uh
i would say that i've used little
philosophy
in
motivating i hadn't used little
philosophy and motivating and sort of
the science i did
um my mother happened to be a philosophy
professor and so i when i was a kid kind
of took the point of view oh my gosh you
know people are still arguing about the
same stuff they've argued about for 2000
years this field is doomed i'm never
going to do anything to do with
philosophy
but
what i've discovered in my later life so
to speak is that when you get
foundational enough in science you run
into philosophy you run out of the sort
of industrial machine that can be built
in science and you're really dealing
with the foundations and then you have
to think about philosophy because you
have to think about how does this what
is the ultimate foundation of what's
going on here and that's not something
which is going to come back from this
kind of structure that's been built the
big sort of superstructure that's been
built in science
so for example
in
a lot of things i've done recently about
some understanding how we understand why
there are physical laws how can we pick
out the particular laws for our universe
from the set of all possible laws and
from this whole ruliad of the sort of
entangled computations and the
realization that it all is to do with us
as kind of observers of the system and
the nature of our consciousness and how
it relates to what's going on in these
systems
and in what i've done in meta
mathematics recently
i realized that this whole philosophical
question of is mathematics a real thing
are there sort of ideal forms in the
sense of plato that's something that
actually has immediate consequences for
one's real approach to doing sort of
meta mathematics and mathematics but i
think that historically
the the role of philosophy as a driver
of science has been rather poor
i mean i think that
if one looks at
uh and you know there were many kind of
um uh sort of uh
things that happened there i mean for
example you know famously in the time of
galileo in the early 1600s
um
there was sort of the big question
of you know should we
should we
in a sense trust what we can think about
by common sense
the kinds of things that have arisen
they have been sort of
put into concrete form in you know
biblical texts and so on and and then
built on conceptually in theology but in
the end it was about what can we just
figure out by pure philosophical thought
versus what does science have to
parachute in and show us
and that had been the big thing with
copernicus of you know one could by by
apparently pure thought deduce that you
know the earth is standing still et
cetera et cetera et cetera and then sort
of the science parachuted in and said
well actually that's not true
so this this kind of transition from
that which you could figure out by pure
thought you know aristotle in his views
of science it's mostly kind of common
sense plus logical deduction was kind of
the approach here um and uh
so when that got sort of broken by this
idea of oh there's this whole pile of
formal science that you can build that
makes use of mathematics and this and
that
um the um
that's um
that was a place which kind of squashed
out
this kind of it's common sense plus
philosophical in the sense of sort of
pure rational reasoning about what's
going on
and i think that if one tries to look
through sort of the history of um
of developments in science
um i would suspect that
the in the end
serious developments in science require
essentially a philosophical component
but often that is barely even described
by the creators of those developments
i think that um if we look at i don't
know
uh
turing and the universal computer
uh that was not a very philosophically
driven thing it was a very practical and
solving a math problem this is a
mechanism for doing that now if you look
at um godel for example in godel's
theorem godel actually did have a
philosophical uh motivation
uh he wanted to show that plato's idea
that there's a real thing in mathematics
and these axioms that people like
hilbert had sort of set up as ways to
describe an abstract mathematics that as
hilbert said could be about tables and
chairs as much as it could be about
points and lines
uh girdle said that's not true there's
really an intrinsic there there for
mathematics and he did goodl's theorem
to prove that this sort of formalistic
approach wasn't going to work and that
there really is a there there for
mathematics i think our recent efforts
in the physicalization of matter
mathematics finally sort of vindicate
girdle and plato and show that there
really is a there there in in the
foundations of mathematics in a way that
isn't captured by the sort of axiomatic
approach but that was a sort of
philosophically motivated thing although
most people don't really even know that
i didn't even know that until recently
about girls motivation in doing that
and you know in my own life
there are certainly things which are
i would say almost philosophical things
like um
i mean i'd say that philosophy has
entered in my own life more implicitly
than explicitly until recently this idea
uh you know in early times ideas about
some
computational irreducibility and sort of
using computation as models of the world
and what it means to model the world and
so on
implicitly there's lots of philosophy
there but the way that i thought about
it was not in philosophical terms
a little bit more directly when after
new kind of science and the development
of the principle of computational
equivalence and so on
i was thinking about building what will
become what from alpha something which i
had thought about for decades earlier
but had believed that the only way to
get to or from alpha was by making sort
of a general ai
um and then i realized that if i
believed the principle of computational
equivalence at an almost philosophical
level it implied that there was no
bright line between the intelligent and
the merely computational so given that
we had lots of computational tools well
let's just go and try and build both
alpha and and that was successful so
that was a sort of philosophically
motivated development
now i would say that um
uh in you know it's an interesting thing
to survey different different advances
in science and which ones kind of were
kind of philosophy first
i would say that for me
i tend to build the science and then as
i try to really understand why does it
work that way
then one dives into philosophy so for
example understanding why the laws of
physics and the fundamental laws of
mathematics that we seem to be deducing
why that works that way and why that's
sort of in the eye of the beholder and
involves us as human observers that
becomes pretty deeply philosophical um i
think that one could say something like
understanding that space
is made of stuff
that that's a philosophical kind of
question you know i wrote a piece
recently called on the concept of motion
one could have said at least back a
couple of thousand years that's a
philosophical idea
why can things move in modern times that
would philosophy would have been thrown
out of that discussion it's now sort of
back um because we're thinking about
things in a more foundational level
and um
so i think um
uh
the question of of sort of the
interaction between science and
philosophy there's sort of the
frameworks for thinking about science
um there's
uh
and then
there's the sort of uh in a sense a lot
of the important uh directions in
science are defined by some strategies
for science does the philosophy give one
a sort of a path a strat a strategic
path
for me it has a few times
i would say in general that is not a
common thing
the uh sort of uh
understanding i mean that there are
areas of science like neuroscience for
example where some people kind of use
philosophy as a guiding
strategy for some of the things that
they think about
um i'm not sure quite how successful
that is and i think perhaps many people
say it's it's much safer to be a um
um
a kind of uh we're just dissecting
pieces of brains and deducing things
from it than to make these kind of
philosophical statements you know i was
giving advice to a person who's been
working with us who who does a mixture
of mathematics and physics and
philosophy
and he's trying to decide should he
should he get a job
in a um in a physics department or in a
philosophy department
and so i made the point if you're in a
physics department the physicist will
look down on the philosophy you do if
you're in a philosophy department the
philosophers will look up to the physics
that you do
so you're probably better off in a
philosophy department and it's been
interesting because of the work i've
been doing recently in metamathematics
i've had a bit more visibility into sort
of the modern philosophy departments and
i would say that the um
uh
in there's there's much more sort of
content knowledge i would say of
particular areas that now seems to exist
there i will make one comment which is
that i've i've talked quite a bit about
some some of the things we've done in
our physics project for example in
different audiences different groups of
people
and i i've been
and maybe it's a selection effect i've
been rather impressed generally at the
philosophers relative to the scientists
in modern times because the scientists
don't expect to actually have to think
about anything big
they expect that if you're telling them
about something it's like well we've got
an incremental piece of progress because
that's the way science has mostly
progressed
and so if you'd say this is a big idea
they're like we don't know how to think
about big ideas we know how to think
about specific developments whereas the
philosophers are kind of much more it's
all big ideas they've been churning ever
since antiquity and it's big ideas all
the way so to speak not always but
that's that seems to be one one dynamic
and so that means when you talk about
big ideas
uh they're kind of much more attuned to
listening for how to think about big
ideas than typical modern scientists are
i think there are other aspects of sort
of the interaction between philosophy
and science
uh some of the kinds of things about um
you know in a sense
there's philosophy where you can discuss
it you can discuss this space relative
or absolutely you can discuss it's free
will this determinism and so on but in
the end you can make precise scientific
theories about these things and that's
sort of an interesting moment when the
philosophy segues into precise science
and i've seen a bunch of that happen in
some of the projects we've been doing
i've been doing over the last few
decades
um it's also another thing that happens
is sometimes the philosophy if you're
dealing with ethics or something like
this
sometimes the uh you know in the end the
thing that has been debated in ethics
forever and ever has to turn into a
piece of code that decides where to turn
the steering wheel of the self-driving
car
so do they have steering wheels well yes
they do still but um uh
actually i just saw one example one that
doesn't so so that'll be an anachronism
soon enough but in any case the the
point is what what starts as a
philosophical discussion about trolley
problems and things like that in the end
it's piece of code and that's sort of an
interesting process that's happening
right now same thing with political
philosophy um in a sense you know there
are there are questions there about you
know as the ai runs the central bank as
the ai decides things about you know
propaganda versus uh communication and
so on uh you know what does that uh you
know what what was a piece of political
philosophy will turn into a piece of
code and that's a an interesting thing
that's happening in
in the present time and actually a
reason why
sort of uh the more people get educated
about sort of philosophical ideas
you know many of these ideas it's kind
of funny you know you see these
discussions about things about so this
or that sort of political philosophy
kind of question
and and you realize boy you know that
was already people were talking about
that 2000 years ago there's been a lot
figured out about that you know it may
be one may not know what the answer is
but it certainly is the case that if you
take some point of view that comes in
trained with lots of other consequences
of that point of view and that's had a
couple of thousand years to be worked
out but when people come it's kind of
like the question of do you know history
uh you know in okay in science it tends
to be the case
that the latest is best we've got to a
certain stage in some area of science
and the surface is what you need to know
about typically roughly
um in
in something like history
well you could say we don't care about
the past we learn nothing from it we
don't need to learn you know back back
the you know the history of the ancients
and so on um
but actually it does seem like there's a
lot one can learn from history and i
think philosophy a little bit the same
kind of way there are questions that
have been discussed for thousands of
years and they're the same questions
that we're discussing today and it isn't
the case that you just say what's the
latest let me refer only to the paper
that was published in the 2010s you know
anything before that oh no no that can't
be relevant that might be the right
thing for some area of biomedicine it's
not the right thing for these
fundamental questions and things like
philosophy
um
comment here from
a woman i think a lot of places in
history the role of academic pursuit was
that of a philosopher that academic
pursuit has attained a large amount of
division of labor yeah i mean i think
that that is to some extent true that
that academia
was
you know academia in the 1200s
was often training for the church and
theology and so on and theology was sort
of a principle place where thinking
and serious intellectual pursuits were
concentrated
and i think that the
as sort of
practicalizable things like science
became more prominent
you know the role of universities has
been much more
let's let's deliver the practical
results skills etc um than this thing
about let's i mean this is a long
discussion not for today about sort of
the role of universities and their
relationship between sort of the
transmission of knowledge across
centuries versus the development of new
knowledge versus kind of the the
promotion of the of the news so to speak
and these are all different roles that
one can kind of discuss
and debate you know what the right place
for those things is for example
returning to the wolfram institute and
our efforts there
in a sense what we what we're doing
there is something which is sort of a a
new approach
to getting innovative basic science done
it's a different approach than the sort
of the university approach the
university approach has sort of evolved
in that direction over the course of
well particularly the last 50 or so
years but the last time 100 150 years
and this is sort of a somewhat different
approach that is more informed by the
success of corporate r d
than it is by what's be what's happened
at universities
um
uh yeah comment from commentaries about
philosophy and mathematical logic and
their overlap
um yeah that's a that's an interesting
topic maybe for another time
i mean i think that the um
uh
you know
part of that overlap i think was driven
by a strange phenomenon which is that
logic was ejected from mathematics uh
the the study of it used to be the case
in ireland in the middle ages or
something people were studying
mathematics they would study logic they
were kind of neck and neck both worth
studying logic more for
for the for rhetoric for structuring
arguments mathematics for calculating
things and so on you know mathematics
built this giant
you know tower structure
and became hugely relevant for the
everyday world and people's practical
lives and that became sort of a big
thing whereas logic kind of withered
away as this obscure thing that nobody
really sort of seemed to care about
um and uh that meant that there was kind
of a human dynamic that there were
mathematics departments and it's like
logicians logicians should they be in
the mathematics department no you know
they should be well in the philosophy
department because after all logic was
invented by aristotle and aristotle was
a philosopher so send them to the
philosophy department so that caused a
bunch of logic and the more advanced
forms of logic turned into mathematical
logic and so on it it caused little
little uh sort of uh
little sort of colonizations of
philosophy departments by what amounted
what became mathematical logic and i
think that's part of the reason why
there's a little bit more cross talk
between philosophy and there are you
know because the logicians were ejected
from mathematics and sent to the
philosophy department that's that's
caused there to be a little bit more
sort of philosophical uh dressing around
mathematical logic
um
oh you guys are asking too many
interesting questions
um
adam is asking are there inherently
philosophical ideas that cannot be
turned into scientific ones can we
distinguish them outright without
knowing future scientific developments i
think no i think any question that is
asked
that is kind of
like why does the universe exist a
philosophical question you might think
except for the fact that last year i
realized there's actual science you can
say about that actually that question
was so philosophical that hadn't really
been touched much even by the
philosophers
but i think a lot of these questions
about kind of um
uh
i think i think in the end
we can start to fill in with science
what was outlined by philosophy in
almost every area i'm i'm hard pressed
to think of ones where where one can't
and i've i've just seen an awful lot of
examples where one has been able to i
think that um
uh
even
well these areas where where philosophy
um intersects with things like theology
um i've been surprised like the question
like why does the universe exist
is something that has a whole
theological dimension
where
it's not about you know what was written
in this or that sacred book it's about
kind of the type of thinking that goes
on when you think globally about the
nature of the universe and so on which
is something which has been the purview
of theology more so than certainly more
so than science over the course of time
so i think it it's um i i must say that
it might almost be a formula for for
seeing future science to say what is the
discussion in philosophy
that has not yet been scientized now
when i say scientized i'm a little bit
you know afraid of using that term
because to many people science means the
paradigm that arose in the 1600s where
everything is turned into a number more
or less
but that's not the only story of science
these paradigms of science that have
come up the computational paradigm from
the 1980s the multi-computational
paradigm from now those are different
ways to make formal
something that might otherwise be just
thought of as philosophy to make make it
into something that you can actually do
things with compute with build on
incrementally uh make progress in and i
think that's a that in a sense is my
kind of definition of what it means to
do science is something where there's a
formal structure that allows incremental
progress not necessarily turn everything
into numbers write down formulas be able
to work out the answer it's that there
is a formal structure that allows you to
make progress
so i think that um
when i say there are questions about oh
i don't know the philosophy of around
human nature political philosophy these
kinds of things
it isn't the case that i expect when i
say to scientize them i don't expect
that that means somebody's going to be
able to say and that means that the rate
you know the interest rate from the
central bank is going to be x because
that leads to this income distribution
and that's proved to be right by science
that's not going to happen
that's it's still a it's a different
it'll be different kinds of scientific
questions different things you could say
that have a formal structure that aren't
the things that were sort of the numbers
version of science that came from the
1600s you know i was struck recently in
terms of those kinds of questions by a
piece of history i didn't know about
francis bacon
um who was kind of a a um
sort of a an originator of the modern
scientific method story
um and he was also a courtier in england
uh with elizabeth the first i guess if
i'm getting my dates correct
um
the and um
you know one of the things that he
realized was
if you can prove it by science
the public should believe you
and so he kind of developed this idea of
let's have this notion of the scientific
method and the prove it by science kind
of approach
because then we don't have to just argue
with rhetoric you know believe us we're
you know we're we're sort of telling you
the right thing rhetorically instead one
can just say look you can just do
science and that's the answer and that's
the ultimate absolute truth so to speak
i think that um um i i'm a little bit
horrified by the fact that that story
has arguably been overplayed in the
story of the pandemic and this and that
and the other of you know we've derived
it from science so boom we know the
absolute truth um in fact you know often
things are much less certain than one
might assume from that and that's partly
a consequence of computational
irreducibility it's partly the nature of
science and what's knowable and kind of
a whole sort of philosophical chain
there but it but it is interesting to
see the uh you know the extent to which
i think the questions of philosophy um
end up being things which ultimately i
think
will mostly end up being formalizable in
some way that goes beyond the merely
rhetorical and that will be the moment
at which they start to turn into things
that we can think of as being related to
science
all right we should wrap up there thanks
for lots of interesting questions and
comments and uh i see there are more
saved up for another time
but let's wrap up here for now and
thanks for joining me and